they say virtually nothing is impossible
in this world if we put our mind towards
it and maintain a positive attitude well
I focused on my passion of becoming a
digital marketer and with the help of
Simply learn I was even able to crack a
job with 30 hike in my salary
hi I'm Karthik srinivas currently living
in Bangalore and working as a key
account manager at Green honchos I was
working as a BPO executor for almost two
years after my graduation and during the
lockdown one of my friend introduced me
to digital marketing and after that I
got really interested towards it I
learned basic digital marketing courses
online then I joined a mid-size digital
marketing agency in coimbatore as an
intern and after eventually completing
my intern I learned to run ads and I was
promoted as a Performance Marketing
executor in the same agency but I felt
that like I lack knowledge somewhere the
knowledge that I had was like bits and
pieces so I really felt that I need a
proper certification course to
understand in depths of like digital
marketing after my basic research online
I decided to go with professional
certificate program in digital marketing
with Purdue University I think it was a
great decision I was able to learn the
fundamentals of digital marketing from
basic level to the advanced level the
course was divided into six modules and
each modules explained about different
aspects of digital marketing and it was
what just I needed so after completing
the course I was able to perform well in
my company and I got promoted as a team
lead yeah after few months I got a
better job opportunity in Bangalore as a
assistant manager for account management
at green honchos with a decent 30 hike
in my salary I really feel happy with
the trajectory of my life and the career
so far I feel that like everyone should
keep learning and improving their skills
on a regular basis following that
philosophy I am taking another course
with simply learn I advise every
professional out there to keep looking
for ways to upskill themselves
[Music]